Look at the E F F's.
Yeah, excuse me.
Joo Joo's Red Revolutionary Party has recently
released their manifesto for the upcoming
Otham elections.
And their main concerns are as follows.
Land expropriation without compensation,
nationalisation of mines and banks,
building government capacity
so that tenders are no longer needed.
But I don't know if Uncle Perversion
and mclanga would like that very much.
Free education,
healthcare, houses and sanitation,
protected industrial development,
a move from reconciliation in Africa to justice
and a corrupt free government.
The largest emphasis is placed on land and jobs
as their theme for this year is our land and jobs now.
And also stop,
stop loging like,
please, like. Yeah.
Julius Malema,
whether you like him or not,
agree with his viewpoints or not,
you cannot deny that the man is an incredible
politician. Does this mean he'd be a good president?
Probably not.
But that's up to you to decide.
So register to vote.